[Música]
y
cómo
la historia que traigo para compartir es
una historia de amor
para mí es extraño estar aquí arriba en
un escenario sola y al mismo tiempo muy
acompañada porque hoy somos aquí cientos
de personas que estáis mirando hacia
aquí y me escucháis sin posibilidad de
intervención y sin embargo tenéis que
decidir algo fundamental os venís de
viaje a donde quiero llevaros o nos
quedamos aquí mi abuelo estuvo aquí en
este mismo escenario hace muchos años
también mi abuela se subió a estas
tablas quizás ellos sintieron algo
similar al pudor que yo siento ahora
fernando que es el nombre de mi abuelo
era una persona tan tímida que según
dicen no era capaz de entrar a una
mercería a comprar unos calcetines
porque le daba vergüenza ese mismo
fernando se subía a un escenario y se
transformaba en un ser absolutamente
impúdico libre de todo sentido del
ridículo
así que allá donde esté en la galaxia
lejana o cercana que haya decidido
habitar espero que tengan algo similar o
en relación a la tecnología que tenemos
hoy para solicitarle que me ayude a
contar esta historia vamos a ver
vaya hombre empezaba a ponerme triste
aquí tan solo pero me parece que vamos a
pasarlo muy bien bien empecemos por
imaginar una casa una casa rodeada de un
inmenso jardín allí una mujer del todo
excepcional muere a los 69 años se llama
emma cohen y entre otras muchas cosas
fue actriz
fue escritora
fue directora amiga de personas plantas
animales amigas de todo lo que palpita
amiga grande y niña y la persona que me
enseñó a mirar
emma es también nuestra guía en este
viaje que estamos haciendo hoy antes de
morirse
emma toma una decisión he tomado una
decisión que cambiará nuestras vidas
emma decide y así me lo comunica que
cuando muera su casa será para mí como
sabéis vivimos en sociedades donde el
derecho a la vivienda no se cumple donde
cada año miles de personas deben
abandonar su única casa solo en la
comunidad de madrid' donde estamos ahora
se produce una media de 13 desahucios
por día en medio de este panorama a mí
me cae una casa entonces no puedo no
sentir este gran privilegio de clase y
también en parte del azar agradecida a
emma me olvido del asunto hasta nuevo
aviso para entonces yo llevaba tiempo
investigando sus trabajos y los de su
compañero de vida y hogar
fernando fernán gómez que igual que ella
entre otras muchas cosas fue actor
fue escritor
fue director
también fue abuelo
indagar en lo que hicieron es una forma
de conocerlos de estar cerca de ellos y
mientras los conozco y me acerco escribo
el guión para una película sobre ellos
el caso es que la decisión de emma
cambia mi vida hasta tal punto que poco
a poco me veo convertida en un personaje
del guión que estoy escribiendo en mã
muere yo me instalo en la casa y a día
de hoy sigo trabajando en la película de
modo que desde hace dos años vivo en un
escenario arriba estrella el gran teatro
del mundo de espera
[Música]
más alto por favor la música viva puede
estar un poco más alta
así
[Música]
este escenario se llama luna y consta de
interior casa con varios ambientes donde
se desarrolla la trama y exterior jardín
con huerto y allí están sus restos
los restos de ellos los de fernando bajo
los rosales los demás sobre la higuera
debajo de la higuera viven dos gallinas
de nombre capón a jonathan en honor y en
amor a la gallina caponata dentro de
cuyo plumaje emma pasó la temporada
televisiva del 79 al 80
cuando llegó a la casa comienzo a dormir
en su cama a desayunar en sus tazas a
usar su ropa
a leer sus libros sus cuadernos sus
cartas sus secretos a estas alturas del
viaje estoy completamente enamorada de
ellos me veo intentando imitar los es
como si quisiera quedarme los dentro
apropiarme de lo que me resulta más
admirable de emma la revolución su
manera de estar y de ser y su generosa
inteligencia
de fernando su espléndida ironía ante la
vida y su olor
de su forma de acompañarse y amarse
extraigo una lección de amor libre de
sus trabajos
me encantaría absorber el genio la
capacidad de concentración el rigor el
humor la magia la diversión la libertad
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cada paso que doy invoca y convoca a sus
fantasmas paso mucho más tiempo con
ellos desde que murieron sin duda pero
no hay nada que temer porque son
fantasmas buenos nos han dejado cajas os
he traído una pequeñísima muestra de lo
que nos han regalado es una caja de
sorpresas que se abre y sale otra caja y
de la otra caja sale otra caja y de otra
caja sale otra caja y de la otra caja
sale otra caja y así hasta el fin
esto son fragmentos de un borrador de un
texto de fernando recibos del banco
cartas montones de cartas un programa de
mano de la coartada representada
precisamente en este teatro piques de la
compra un posavasos
una novela de emma negras tierras negras
los storyboards dibujados por fernando
para una de sus películas en este caso
mambrú se fue a la guerra notas notas
que se dejaban entre ellos ésta es una
que más le dejó a fernando buenos días
fernando feliz rodaje te esperamos
en esta historia hay sobreabundancia de
materiales porque nuestros personajes no
paraban de crear y eso que a fernando le
gustaba decir que estaba muy capacitado
para no hacer nada
cada caja cada cajón cada estante cada
rincón de la casa contiene relatos
historias a veces son ideas sueltas o el
inicio de una trama a veces son
proyectos sin terminar notas otras veces
son los guiones completos de películas y
series que nunca llegaron a rodarse como
por ejemplo este que os he traído de la
puerta del sol
con vivo con cientos yo diría que miles
de fragmentos que se comunican conmigo y
con quien quiera escucharlos porque
hablan
en realidad tú eres como todos solo te
crees lo que veis o lo que no se sale ni
un poco de los esquemas establecidos
todo ese trabajo que hicieron con la
palabra y la imagen tiene la magnífica
capacidad de responder a mis preguntas
busco y la mayor parte de las veces
encuentro
lo que sucede es que esas respuestas
generan más preguntas de manera que en
la luna siempre hay algo nuevo que saber
es posible pero me pregunto es posible
que se trate de un sueño
porque el sueño es el alimento más dulce
que se sirve a la mesa de la vida
conocéis esa sensación ese deseo de
decirle algo a alguien que ya no está no
tiene por qué es algo trascendente puede
ser simplemente tener ganas de charlar
no de conversar con alguien importante
que ya fue que abandonó su forma física
digamos que gracias a los trabajos a los
que dedicaron su vida a fernando y emma
podemos seguir conversando con ellos así
que os propongo que imaginemos que
estamos en la casa estamos todas en la
casa bueno en la casa no estamos en el
jardín porque ahí sí que cabemos y
empieza a llover
quiero enseñarte hablo
fernando ha salido del interior de la
casa nos ha invitado a entrar nos
conduce hacia la zona de su estudio de
allí coge una carpeta y extiende su
contenido sobre esta mesa es qué
quiero que sepas quién eras tienes cara
de no acordar te bien
yo sí sé quién fuiste
pero eso era hace tanto tiempo que tú ya
no te acuerdas o no quieres acordarte
mira quién eras
te reconoces
pero mírate bien ni siquiera te has
fijado eras exactamente así a lo mejor
no sabes quién eres ahora
de repente en ma traviesa el salón va
hasta la cocina y se sirve un café
amo y luego otro versión a lo más bonito
de todo
al que te pido que hagas una foto mía
mira
bueno no queda mal lo pongo unos simples
es que son como joyas
ya dije que emma me enseñó a mirar y si
miramos bien a nuestro paso por la luna
notaremos que nos van dejando notas por
ejemplo esto
es difícil que la gente común conozca el
pasado siempre hay interés en deformar
lo en ocultarlo
gran parte de los libros y los artículos
que escribió fernando también algunas de
sus películas tratan sobre el pasado
sobre la relación que tenemos con la
memoria y con su contrario el olvido es
un tema que le preocupa y le ocupa la
necesidad de recordar quizás por que
vivió una guerra civil vivió 40 años de
dictadura vivió una supuesta transición
a otro sistema vivió otro sistema que
llamamos democracia y a fin de cuentas
tras 80 años de vida como él mismo
escribió en el poder siguen los de
siempre
hay que recordar hay que recordar
recuerdo también una nota de emma pero
como no la recuerdo de memoria la voy a
leer
nadie es libre hasta que pierde el miedo
al miedo porque lo ha perdido todo las
palabras han de ser piedras no cuentas
brillantes para deslumbrar
soy
hay cosas que aparecen de manera
espontánea y otras que buscamos
conscientemente un día estamos con emma
en la luna y encendemos el último
ordenador en el que trabajo fernando
es una obra
tomate está aquí
en el ordenador ha aparecido un texto
escrito por fernando en 1938 de manera
que fernando en los últimos años de su
vida retomó la adolescencia de su
escritura tenía entonces 17 años aquí
había una guerra civil y fue el mismo
año
que le fue emitida esta cartilla de la
cnt del sindicato de espectáculos
el guiñol de papá dick que es el nombre
del texto de 1938 es una historia de
fantasía donde el amor y la sinceridad
vencen a la mentira y la mezquindad
tras el grato descubrimiento apagamos el
ordenador y nos vamos a hacer la comida
así como mi nieta elena y luna gin house
ahora la tortilla se romperá
porque he puesto demasiado
perdóname
ha sido la ambición
la bula he sido mar y pp por un momento
pero yo soy mar y pepi con las tortillas
y otros son con los humanos y las
tortillas aunque tengan un corazoncito
las tortillas de este lado
pero no sufren tanto
como los humanos
a pesar de su profunda empatía con los
sufrimientos y los padecimientos de
nuestra especie en madera de las que
sufrir no sufría mucho
no iba con su carácter es más vino aquí
a disfrutar
puedes tener una línea sencilla una
neurona gorda
y yo estoy con la gorda
estoy en ello a veces es duro estar aquí
sin ti sin ti sin el abuelo rodeada de
toda vuestra vida
qué hacer con todo esto que hacemos con
el pasado lo tiro lo quemó lo hacemos
desaparecer y aquí no ha pasado nada
escucha escucho
estoy de cierto que su viaje es una
hermosa memoria
la memoria es la vida
hay que recordar hay que recordar
supongo que es eso lo que me mueve a
clasificar y organizar todo lo que
dejaron al marcharse con el deseo de que
toda esa imaginación y sabiduría que han
quedado dentro de la casa puedan ser
compartidas con todas vosotras y con las
que vengan después de nosotras a
continuar este viaje
y hemos llegado al final que no es el
final de nada más que de esta charla
honestamente creo que no he cumplido lo
que ofrecía al principio contar una
historia lo que sí
he intentado es que me acompañará es que
fuerais todas pasajeras de este viaje
alguna parte espero al menos haber
logrado explicar algo que algunas
personas que vienen a la luna les
resulta raro excéntrico y es que en dos
años que llevo viviendo en la casa no
haya modificado apenas nada que haya
papeles que han quedado en el mismo
lugar y sus cosas sigan en las mesas o
por los armarios que no haya hecho la
casa lo que decimos más mía con mis
cosas pero mis cosas ahora son los
recuerdos y los deseos
yo no quiero transformar la luna yo
quiero que la luna me siga transformando
a mí muchas muchas gracias
no
[Música]